[Music]
well good evening and welcome to Tucker
Carlson tonight White House senior
policy advisor Stephen Miller is on the
set tonight he was at Camp David over
the weekend as the president and several
top congressional Republicans hashed out
their priorities on immigration and
welfare reform Noah then appeared on CNN
yesterday to discuss all of this but the
conversation quickly went off the rails
over Michael Walsh nubuck CNN pulled the
plug on the interview reason why I want
to talk about the president's
experiences what I've seen with him
traveling to me dozens of foreign
leaders with his incredible work okay
you're not answering the questions yeah
I understand you have 24 hours a day of
Aunt Stephen Imperial you're not gonna
give three minutes for the American
people gather the real exterior model
chose one viewer that you care about
right now and you're being obsequious
or being a fan of them in order to
please him wasted enough my view was
like you know as Republicans lawmakers
sessions to resign well that got pretty
intense and it continued during the
commercial break we know that because
someone had CNN leaked a transcript of
Miller's post interview remarks they
were apparently on tape was all done in
an effort to embarrass him joins us
tonight Stephen or thank so for coming
up hey thank you for having so CNN
called around to news organizations
today and said that you were escorted
off the set by security presumably you
were not a physical threat you were not
armed my question is they but they
thought you were a threat do you think
if you had been I don't know a member of
ms-13 here illegally that CNN would have
had security pull you off the set well I
assume if I was a member of ms-13 here
illegally they would be clamoring to get
me into the voting booth but I think
that I think that that like many things
CNN says this story has the most
important virtue of all CNN stories of
being not true well here's what we know
is true and here's an amazing story was
very much to me about the whole thing so
there was a video apparently taken
without your knowledge of you on the set
after the segment ended during the
commercial break and someone apparently
from seeing I don't know who else would
have access to it leaked that to other
news organizations what do you make of
that
well it's just another example of CNN's
very low journalistic standards but I
was glad to have people hear what I said
on camera and off camera which that CNN
has been extraordinarily bias
extraordinarily unfair to the president
and it's not giving their information
their viewers honest information so you
wanted to talk about immigration and the
daca debate is obviously the focus of a
lot energy in the Congress right now the
the priorities for the administration
you have said are ending chain migration
financing a border wall in ending the
diversity lottery of those three what
would you say is the most important
priority from your point of view well
look we need them all because the
reality is is that anything you do on
daca is going to have some predictable
consequences right you're going to have
a an increase in new illegal
immigrations you need to have a wall you
need to close the enforcement loopholes
and then you're also going to have an
increase in the overall number of people
coming into the country and that's why
you have to deal with chain migration
you have to deal with the Visa Lottery
and these are crucial reforms to make
the system work for Americans you know
Donald Trump has a very radical idea and
that's that when we make changes to our
immigration laws the group was you most
concerned about our everyday hardworking
Americans the citizens who make this
country run who obey the laws follow the
rules pay their taxes show up and vote
the people who are loyal to this country
and Donald Trump is saying our country
should be loyal to them in return so so
Democrats argue back that ending chain
migration and ending the diversity
lottery would prevent a lot of people
decent people from coming to this
country what's their argument against
financing a border wall what why do you
think they opposed that well as you know
I mean they all voted for a border
barrier a hard physical border barrier
back in 2006 the secure Fence Act Jill
Biden voted for Barack Obama voted for
Hillary Clinton voted for it etc so
that's a it's just a new position they
apparently have that they're opposed to
any what animates it like what why is
that an absolute sticking point for
Democrats so a bunch of them have said
including in leadership we're not
supporting anything that includes
financing a border wall why what if
Democrats oppose a border wall they're
just saying they won't continue to
unending illegal immigration but let me
deal with the other question too you
talked about you they say well you know
if you have chained migration could keep
good people out there's 7 billion people
in the
most of them are good hard-working
decent honest principled people but the
reality is there's a limit to how many
people any country can bring in and we
as a country have a right to say we want
to bring people in based on their
ability to contribute to our economy to
be safe productive citizens and to have
lift the nation as a whole you think
about our current system of chain
migration Tucker so over the last 10
years we've admitted about 10 million
people through our chain migration
system to understand how many people
that is you're talking about every hour
that's about the size of a high school
auditorium every day it's the size of a
large high school every week of small
city every month and medium to average
size city and every year a very large
city is city the size of Washington DC
or almost a San Francisco every single
year just through chain migration what's
the effect of that on taxpayers what's
the effect of that on wage earners
what's the effect and that's that's
legal right that's just folks coming in
on green cards through chain migration
so what's the railways ask this question
of proponents of immigration including
of illegal immigration what's the ideal
number of immigrants people from other
countries moving here every year right
and oftentimes they won't have an answer
to that question well what's what's your
answer the I mean I have I have my own
views on it but I think the important
point is is that ending chain migration
as the president has called for is
necessary not just for economic security
but for national security
you saw the recent attempted terrorist
attack in New York the individual who
came here the was brought through the
chain migration system right they came
with you a nephew green card right and
that's just not a smart way for a
country to run its immigration system so
what should be the criteria for entry
well you know Donald Trump supported the
raise act and it looked at things like
what's your proficiency in the language
what what economic skills do you have
you have a background in sciences you
have a background in engineering do you
have a background in law or writing it
looked at things like your age obviously
you bring in immigrants who are in their
80s or 90s that's gonna have it
significant expense on society so you
want folks primarily in there and
they're working it but what about I mean
we interviewed someone last week I said
well who will pick the strawberries I
mean how how many immigrants low wage
low skilled immigrants do we need a year
for the AG sector well as you as you
know
only about 1% of the immigrant
population in the country works in
agriculture so it's discussed a lot but
it's a very small portion of the overall
labor force the you know the typical job
that a lower skilled immigrant worker
might do might be construction work it
might be hospitality work it might be a
restaurant work or might be not working
at all and just going on to the welfare
system if there isn't a job for that
individual so if there's no clear
economic rationale for our current
immigration system and it doesn't sound
like there is one there's no economist
saying we need to bring in this number
of low-skilled immigrants then why does
the Democratic Party's support our
current system and want to liberalize
our current system so vehemently what
what motivates them well you're asking
the right question but I think in the
context of this debate the question that
the president's putting before the
American people is when we have an
immigration system whose needs are we
fundamentally trying to serve the needs
of special interests the needs of
politicians the needs of foreign
countries and foreign nationals the
needs of our own country our own workers
and so the end of the day our hope for a
bipartisan deal is that you could have
enough Democrats say that listening to
the voters and the voice of the American
people we want a system that serves
American workers first and what Donald
Trump has done that's so exceptional is
for the first time that I can remember
for the first time you can probably
remember we have a president of this
country who he talks about immigration
he tooks he talks about what is right
for the everyday hardworking person
so what makes we're almost at time so I
just want to get to the one quick
political question which is Democrats
have said they're not going to come to
any deal with these three components in
it border wall reducing chain migration
ending diversity lottery where's the
wiggle room on the on the White House
side look Democrats ultimately have to
make a choice they care a lot about
providing a benefit to illegal
immigrants we're saying to them if you
want to make that deal then you have to
deliver benefits for American families
and American taxpayers too and if both
sides are willing to agree to those
terms Tucker then we can have a deal and
most importantly we can have an
immigration system that 10 20 30 50
years from now produces more
assimilation higher wages more Economic
Opportunity and better prospects for
immigrants and us-born alike
Stephen Miller thank you hey thank you